hey guys how's it going so today we're
gonna be talking about the new iPhone 7
there's a huge announcement coming up on
ironically September 7th and I'm pretty
excited as always as I think everybody
is that is watching this video because
most of you guys are pretty big Apple
fans and going with that trend of Apple
fans apples joined Twitter I'm
speechless
Twitter's been out since 2006 and you're
just now joining Twitter Apple excuse me
I have no words
but either way welcome to Twitter every
other company is on Twitter and you guys
decide that oh we're not going to talk
about it though I don't want to talk
about it anyway we're here to talk about
iPhone 7 because the announcement is
coming up very shortly and I've been
covering sort of the news and the rumors
of the past couple of months leading up
to this big moment so let's see but we
can see everything to expect from
Apple's iPhone 7 and Apple watch event
three days 0 hours 5 minutes 45 seconds
if you guys would like to see me do a
livestream of the event give me a like
let me know in the comments because I'm
undecided I've never done a live stream
before I mean I've done a live stream
but I've never done one during an Apple
event so this is going to be pretty
exciting see you on the 7th so this is
something we've already seen before I
covered it I talked about how I thought
this was photoshopped which it still may
or may not be but this is clearly clear
you can see through it which is
something that I completely missed when
I was photoshopping this thing to make
it into what I thought that it should
look like but the biggest news to come
out as of late is that the new iPhone 7
will come in five different colors so as
we can see here there is the usual
silver gold rose gold along with a dark
black which will replace the space gray
and a fifth new color described as piano
black piano black is kind of intriguing
to me right here we can see another
leaked image all of these leaked images
I put them in quotes today's revealing
news it's all planned this is pretty
interesting here it says improved water
resistance matching that of the original
Apple watch which is kind of exciting
because a lot of people I don't think
realized how water resistant to the
Apple watches actually were I can attest
to that because mine went through a full
wash cycle in the washing machine and
came out didn't work and then a few days
later voila magically it started working
again I did make a video about that but
I don't think I ever really followed up
saying how well the Apple watch actually
worked I also made a video recently
talking about how my Apple watch got
shattered which that was my Rose old one
so the one that still went through the
wash cycle still works it was a
stainless steel first version that was
out still works perfectly this is no
news to us no headphone jack with Apple
providing both lightning earpods and a
lightning to 3.5 millimeter jack in the
box
that's good that's important because you
can't be like making people go and
completely replace all of their
headphones because that's just cruel so
fingers crossed that they do have the
adapter included the removal of the
headphone jack will allow for an
upgrades speaker and a new sensor for
improved force touch which we can go
back here that says pressure-sensitive
click less home button to benefit water
resistance new haptics to mimic a
clicking sensation when the button is
pressed which is kind of really not that
necessary because like I push the button
and I know that I push the button
whatever wide color display a better
color quality it's adopted from the nine
point seven inch iPad pro so offer okay
great dual lens and rear camera on the
iPhone 7 plus for a lot of people who
make YouTube content even everyday just
regular normal people who like to make
videos or take photos this is gonna
benefit pretty much everyone so it will
increase apples cost by about forty
dollars could make the iPhone 7 plus
more expensive than the iPhone 6s plus
at this point you're already gouging us
and it's not actually apples fault it's
mostly the carrier's followed we don't
even have to get into that both lenses
12 megapixels one with a wide-angle
camera larger pixel sizes 6p lens and
optical image stabilization well the
second will be a telephoto lens with a
smaller pixel size so that's kind of
cool what I'm going to be really excited
about is to see the apps that sort of
come out of this new dual camera
technology proximity sensor shifting
from LED to laser for faster response
and greater recognition distance as well
as potential gesture recognition right
and if see support rather than putting a
second speaker at the bottom in place of
the headphone jack Apple said to be
upgrading the earpiece receiver at the
top of the device to become a full
speaker
so that's that's about everything that
we're going to be expecting back to this
article everything to expect from
Apple's iPhone 7 so here's some possible
headphones I would lose those in 3.5
seconds better battery system that makes
the phone waterproof and fast charging
it's going to be cool to see if they
really do have wireless charging which
at this point I feel like you're gonna
need to have it just sort of stay in the
game reports that suggested that
supplies the iPhone 7 initially could be
limited meeting the device itself no
please I don't want to sleep outside
again really don't want to sleep outside
what about the Apple watch 2 alongside
the iPhone Apple is going to launch a
second generation of its watch according
to reports the upgraded watch is
expected have GPS connectivity a faster
processor and better battery the battery
really isn't that bad also not good I
mean I charge my phone
pretty much every night so I have sort
of this little dual phone charger and
watch charging station so I use that and
everything sort of works out pretty well
will there be a new iPad is Apple
released the scaled-down version of the
I've had Pro in March I don't think
there's going to be any huge iPad
announcements they'll probably talk
about how many they sold and how people
are just replacing their computers with
iPad pros and this and that's a Janna
what's this interesting these are some
interesting mock-ups if this is in fact
a mock-up these look cool looks real
real nice a new phone a new watch a
missing headphone jack that's basically
it
I have a watch other rumors suggest the
next watch will have better
waterproofing bigger battery a barometer
and the ability to do more things over
Wi-Fi if you have it available blah blah
blah blah well that's pretty much it
guys
I would love to know what you guys think
it's going to be pretty interesting to
see what this event actually pans out to
be since most of the rumors seem to be
out and most of these rumors seem like
pretty legitimate actual truths I think
one of the things that we're still
waiting on is
every wireless charging it looks like
it's going to be super water-resistant
I'm so excited about thank you guys so
much for watching as I said the
beginning this video if you would like
me to do a live stream let me know
because I'm still a little bit undecided
but I think it would be pretty fun to do
that being said I've a bunch of other
videos here so go check those out and
I'll see you guys in the next one bye
I haven't even flipped it around yet but
you guys are seeing it before me